pour cette spéciale consacré au Salon de
l'Automobile à Paris cette spéciale du
78 nous allons nous attarder sur cette
folie du tout électrique l'un des
constructeurs les plus engagés c'est
Renault Renault qui expose notamment ici
la Tiz on va en parler dans un instant
mais qui présente également la Zoé
bonsoir Emmanuel Bouvier vous êtes
responsable de la gamme z0ro émission
donc pour la marque Renault
présentez-nous ce véhicule alors Zoé
c'est véritablement la première voiture
la première CIT citadine de grande
diffusion qui a été conçu dès le départ
comme un véhicule électrique ça veut
dire que toutes les contraintes de
l'électrification ont été intégré dans
sa conception les batteries sont longées
dans le plancher par exemple ce qui
permet d'avoir un design très cohérent
et de ne faire aucun compromis en terme
d'habitabilité ou de volume de coffre
par exemple puisque Zoe a un volume de
coffre de 340 l qui est au meilleur
niveau de son segment donc on retrouve
le même confort que dans un véhicule
classique on retrouve le même confort
que dans un véhicule classique le
silence en plus par que vousavez pas le
bruit du du moteur thermique pour venir
gâcher la zénitude que vous aurez dans
une zo la grosse différence au quotidien
c'est qu'au lieu d'aller à la pompe à la
station service il faut la recharger via
l'électricité est-ce que ça c'est simple
est-ce que c'est facile alors charger sa
voiture c'est extrêmement simple ça peut
se faire à la maison sur une borne de
recharge sécurisée que vous vous faites
poser par un installateur vers lequel n
notre réseau aiguille des clients qui
permet de se charger entre 6 et 9h vous
pouvez également vous charger en voirie
sur des bornes qui commencent à
apparaître en voirie dans les parkings
mais également sur les parkings de
certains supermarché certains
hypermarchés et vous pouvez également
Zoé la charger de façon encore plus
rapide sur des born de charge accélérée
qui commence également à apparaître
notamment chez les hypermarchés une
borne 22 kW ça permet par exemple de se
charger à 80 % en 1 heure une bande 43
kW il y en a quelquesunes qui commenent
à apparaître c'est 80 % de la charge en
1 demh vous venez de le dire ça commence
à apparaître c'est que le début le
succès de cette cette voiture de ce
véhicule est forcément lié au
développement du du parc pour se
recharger du parc de ses bornes est-ce
que Renault va va impulser dans ce
sens-l également alors effectivement le
fait de voir des bornes en voirie ou
dans des endroits publics ça rassure les
clients néanmoins la charge principale
c'est ce que nous constatons sur nos
premier client de Kango Z2 ou de fluance
Z2 elle se passe à domicile c'est un peu
comme un bateau qui rentre tous les
jours à son port d'attache euh ça se
passe à domicile ou sur le parking
d'entreprise pourquoi parce que c'est là
où vous allez vous charger dans les
meilleures conditions économiques vous
allez par exemple vous charger la nuit
au moment où le courant est est moins
cher et donc la charge en voirie la
charge dans le domaine public elle est
plus une charge d'appoint une charge de
réassurance néanmoins son développement
est critique pour permettre la grande
diffusion et tranquilliser complètement
les conducteurs vous visez quel public
avec ce véhicule concrètement c'est pas
des gens qui vont partir en vacances
sont des gens qui vont plutôt aller
travailler alors de banlieu à banlieu
notre public c'est tous les gens dont
les usages sont compatibles avec du
véhicule électrique ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que en Europe de l'Ouest 90 % des
déplacements en font moins de 60 km avec
Zoe nous proposons une autonomie réelle
de l'ordre de 150 km en saison tempérée
une autonomie homologué de 210 km mais
qui reste théorique et qui permet juste
de se comparer avec les autres
concurrents donc tous les gens qui sont
dans cette situation là sont a priori
susceptibles d'être tentés de basculer
vers l'électrique d'être tenté de
basculer vers un véhicule zéro émission
quel coût quelle disponibilité alors
justement ça c'est un argument très
important pour convaincre les gens de
basculer c'est l'argument du coût Zoe
est proposé en France à partir de 13700
€ grâce au bonus gouvernemental de 7000
€ qui a été décidé au mois de juillet
donc 13700 € c'est tout à fait
comparable voir même légèrement
inférieur au prix moyen du segment dans
lequel elle évolue ça c'est le premier
point ensuite nous proposons la batterie
en location à 79 €. vous avez ajouté à
ce prix de 79 € le coût des plins
électriques c'est à peu près 2 € un PR
électrique un peu moins si vous le
faites la nuit et vous vous rendez
compte que très rapidement au-delà de
10000 km par an vous avez économiquement
intérêt à basculer vers un véhicule
électrique et ce sera disponible quand
alors alors première livraison dans la
foulée du salon avant la fin de l'année
hein nous ouvrons les commandes pendant
les journées publiques du salon et
arrivver en masse du véhicule dans les
affaires et dans les autres pays
d'Europe à partir de début 2013 merci
Emmanuel Bouvier pour toutes ces
précisions concernant ce véhicule
présenté ici au Salon de l'automobile on
reste sur le stand de Renault